what does empathy look and sound like in
a corporate environment so for example a
manager walks into somebody's office and
says you've missed your numbers this
quarter you know we've had this
conversation three three times before
and if you don't hit your numbers the
next quarter I don't know what's going
to happen right that's a fairly normal
uh scenario if you inject empathy into
that scenario it goes a little
differently the manager walks into the
office or calls them up and says you
know you've missed your numbers for the
third time in a row we've had this
conversation before are you okay I'm
worried about you what's going on that's
that's a a muscle that has to be
developed where that person feels that
someone has their back that someone
cares for them and that pays back in
spades over the course of time and
people will give their Blood Sweat and
Tears uh to serve and give back and
follow a leader who they believe sees
them as a human being and cares about
their well-being as a human being
not just if they're hitting their
numbers